thank you for joining me my name is
nirav mehta i am director of product
management for google cloud compute
engine i'd like only 20 minutes of your
time today
the first half i want to share with you
some of our recent innovations but also
the core principles that drive them and
for the second half i'll be
talking with omar hussain who will join
me from applovin
he's a vp of operations i'm very excited
to have him here for a short
conversation
so let's get right to it and uh you know
start with some of the investment themes
and principles that drive us
first
google cloud compute engine
is all about offering you thoughtful and
intuitive choices
what this means is
it's easy for you to select the right
virtual machine type the right storage
type
simply by
looking at how we've organized our
choices by workloads
or by use case
and i'll talk about that in a couple of
minutes
second
package solutions that allow you to very
easily in an opinionated way deploy
uh you know for example sap hana or
vmware microsoft sql server
we've thought through
reference architectures
and common deployment templates to help
you get to outcomes quickly
third
and perhaps the most central
tenet that we have behind the platform
engineering is
simplicity at scale
many customers i talk with
tell me that google cloud is intuitive
and as they use it more they find it
simpler and that we make complex things
seem simple this is
very important to us we take it to heart
and want to ensure we maintain this as
we grow add more features
so it's a commitment to maintain this
advantage
i talk about how we do it
security is paramount
not only making sure that we offer all
the right security controls
and compliance controls but also that we
put privacy in the hands of the
customer or in the control of you
who owns the data
a simple example of this is
our recent feature for encrypting
in-memory contents within a virtual
machine
the encryption keys are controlled by
the customer and turning the feature on
is a matter of simply checking one box
so simple security that's comprehensive
with the customer remaining in control
and lastly cost optimization in all its
forms not just offering the right price
points the right price performance
points
but also helping you
reduce waste
making machine learning based
recommendations that tell you what types
you should be using how you should be
adjusting your spend
all of that comes together to make this
a highly cost optimized platform so
let's talk about each of these starting
with vm families
with vm families
at the very
highest level there are two categories
workload optimized and general purpose
for workload optimized there are three
categories compute optimized
for high performance computing and these
are heavier on compute power
or memory optimized
or the m series of vms
this is for the high-end databases like
sap hana
with very
high configuration of ram
and lastly there is accelerator
optimized which is
gpu-enabled vms for machine learning
training inference
i'll talk about a couple of these soon
and looking at general purpose we have
again
three different categories ranging from
price optimized or cost optimized
to
[Music]
price performance optimized for scale
out
our cost optimized family is called the
e-series or the efficient series
if price per vm is is or price per core
is the most important consideration
that's the one you would pick
if you want a balance and a feature set
that works for the long tail of
general purpose applications you would
go for the n series
and the newest addition to the vm family
is the t-series or the tau vms
these are optimized with a lean feature
set eliminating waste
and offering only the right features for
scale out digital native applications
at a very attractive price point
specifically we tested our tau vms
against competitive options from leading
clouds
and as you see here we've achieved a
price point that's 42 percent better in
price performance than anything else
from a leading cloud
this includes
anything with an intel amd or arm
processor
we are committed to all these cpu types
but what's interesting is with tao vms
we've achieved the the leading price
performance point
with amd vms that means
your developers don't have to go
port from an x86 application to arm or
another type
and still achieve this price performance
tau vms are in preview and we are open
for registration now
an example of recent innovation for
accelerated optimized vmzs are a2vms
these were the first vms to introduce
the nvidia a100 gpu
and i'm very proud
that we have delivered the
largest single instance vm with up to 16
nvidia a100 gpus among leading clouds
so that you can bring your machine
learning training workloads
achieve the scale and performance you
need
and grow with google cloud
another thing that's new with virtual
machines is our spot vms spot vms are a
new and enhanced version of our
preemptable vms
which
allow you
to use our infrastructure when it is not
being used by us so that you can get
very attractive price points
what's interesting here is we
guarantee 60 minimum savings which we
believe is
one of the most compelling price points
in the market
second and more importantly this pricing
is predictable
quite often for this type of vm you will
see in the market the prices vary every
five minutes
in our case these virtual machines
are much more predictable in pricing
and the variation is not more frequent
than once a month
third
kubernetes engine also supports spot vms
so you can take advantage of the price
point
from the kubernetes clusters
and in doing so
we have made sure that the preemption
when it does happen is very
graceful and lastly you can combine this
price benefit with custom machine types
custom machine types allow you to
pick the exact point for
the number of cores and memory so that
you don't have any waste that is often
caused by having predefined machine
sizes
moving on to block storage
again a simple set of choices at the
very left you are optimized for cost we
call it the persistent disk efficient
category
the efficient category will be released
next year
in the middle as you try to seek a
balance of price and performance we have
pd balanced
and then as you go to the right you have
the more performance intensive storage
options
pd performance and pd extreme
for example pd extreme would be used for
the highest end sap hana databases
delivering up to 1200k iops
so we talked about compute and storage
let me address simplicity
at scale
with two features that were released
though you know
recently
and we are continuously enhancing those
features with new capabilities first is
vm manager
this is a suite of tools that allow you
to do three things patch management
config management and inventory
management for operating systems
combined together this allows very easy
visibility into the posture of your
operating system compliance
quickly identify where you're out of
compliance and then launch from the
dashboard
or
in an automatable manner the remediation
to bring it back to compliance
this is very
important for managing vm fleets at
scale
having this sort of burden and toil
removed uh by having it managed by the
platform saves a lot of time and costly
labor
similar to vm management
we have this feature called managed
instance groups
but in this case instead of managing the
vms you're actually managing a group of
vms as a composite application which is
much more intuitive if this is what you
want to do you can achieve that with
google cloud
for example as shown here we can
auto heal
applications so for example some of the
vms in a group stop working the rest of
the vms will take over the load and when
the vms are
healed
they're put back into the group and they
start managing the load with the rest of
the group
we can also achieve auto scaling and
talk about that
and things like auto updating
it's very important that
the managed instance groups are
stateful so you can deliver stateful
applications not just stateless
applications
we support that so let's talk about auto
scaling with managed instance groups you
can scale up and scale down as needed
most often customers in the past have
been using scheduled auto scaling so
if you're expecting a peak at 9 00 a.m
then a little bit in advance of that
schedule auto scaling and then
later in the day
have an auto scale down
with
with google cloud you can do another
thing in addition to schedule
auto scale
you can use
machine learning
to have the platform recommend
or automatically scale up and scale down
the managed instance groups based on
past patterns of traffic this is very
useful when you're in a business where
you don't quite know
you know how your traffic might evolve
over time
and so using machine learning at scale
we are able to drive auto scaling with
managed instance groups
so in summary i've covered a few of
these core principles that drive us
hopefully you see
how our investments
are really
you know
driven by
all the principles that i've shared here
over time i hope to come back to you and
share much more
and now i am very excited to have with
me omar hussain vp of operations at
applovin
applovin is a leading marketing platform
that helps mobile app developers grow
their applications
omer welcome and thank you for being
with us
glad to be here nero
so omar let's start with your
migration to google cloud
you achieved one of the faster
migrations closing down several data
centers
and uh coming over to google cloud in a
very short time
i'd like to
have you tell us a little bit about
how you went about it what were some of
the key tools
practices that you used
in achieving the speed of migration that
you did
yeah sure
um
our journey did start over on on-prem
data centers
and
we found as our business continued to
grow
they no longer could
scale with us
and we looked at google cloud for that
and we leveraged tools like google cloud
interconnect
to help with our migration initially
um and then tools like terraform
um and chef to
build up our our infrastructure
um
we found that terraform was really
simple with google cloud
and leveraged a lot of the apis
underneath
and we were able to build our
data centers really fast and efficiently
what was
the rough time frame uh and and you know
i think you did quite a few data centers
within
a few days
yeah sure we built out our
infrastructure first on google cloud
and when it came to migration day uh we
were confident enough to do five data
center migrations in a single day
wow
very good
i'm sure a lot of planning but also a
lot of
skills
uh thoughtful training that went into it
how did you go about
guiding your teams
to you know to embrace a new concept
because they were working with
on-premise data centers what were some
of the
observations there
yeah sure part of that was
working with google's pso team
along with just reading
a lot of documentation
and understanding the best practices of
it
from there we started to automate uh and
build out our terraform
um
scripts and modules
and
uh
it was easy from there so the support
for terraform having the right libraries
was important to you you found
the google support to be complete enough
that you could you just be productive
absolutely yeah um you know the team was
the google team was very responsive yeah
and if we needed a new feature it was
built out
within a week
good good to know
uh
with respect to once you arrived on
google cloud and how you scaled up
what benefits you saw can you can you
start with maybe what were some of the
first observations you had in hey
this is working a lot better than it
used to
yeah the impact was immediate
we saw that in our
kpis internally
we saw latency drop by 25 percent
we were just able to handle a lot more
we saw
in addition to that
you know a material impact to the
business
what about slas
how how have your uh sla to the business
changed as a result of this move
uh we were able to tighten up our slas
um
given that things were performing faster
we were skilled out more
and doing this all in the midst of a
growing business
um
you know
i'm pretty proud to say that we were
able to just do more and
and cheaper yeah that's great yeah
that's what we like to hear
let's talk about the
uh
network resilience
the overall resilience of the platform
where did you see
advantages in terms of eliminating
single points of failure
yeah sure
when we were on prime we would have
uh
nat based load balancers
and we found what moving into google
cloud we didn't quite need that anymore
and
by eliminating that single point of
failure and really a choke point
we felt more confident in our
infrastructure
and particularly in
failover scenarios where traffic can
increase by a lot
more significantly
we had an ease of mind there great yeah
good to know
i think the collection of different
availability features come together to
support your applications and
knowing how you've used those features
to deliver
scale to your business is very useful to
us you know it realizes
the promise of what we like to deliver
i want to also talk about things that
you're doing that are above the raw
virtue machine layer
tell us about any services you're using
in higher order services in google cloud
beyond virtual machines
yeah sure we're
using data proc today um what are you
using there for uh we're using that for
our machine learning algorithms
and be able to do that at scale
in fact it was actually one of the first
services
we used at google
and
as we were growing and scaling our
business and doing more
ml
we were
we found that doing that on-prem would
just be
a capex feat
and it would be
uh
you know really take a long time to
build
and so when we you know saw data proc it
felt like a natural fit
and able to scale out and not only
scale out but also lower slas and do
that a cost efficient manner yeah and a
lot more elastic i imagine because the
nature of these workloads is there
they go up and down unpredictably
correct
so that's what you meant by capex and
not having to spend
on those peaks
exactly
makes a lot of sense
so you know i think
as i reflect back you've migrated
almost the entire platform over to
google cloud
achieved a larger regional footprint
better slas better performance
cost savings we couldn't ask for
more
thank you so much omar that is an
impressive journey
the speed with which you migrated over
to google cloud how you scaled how you
took advantage of all our principles to
improve your resilience offer better
slas better performance it's all the
things we love to see
in our customer so thank you for taking
the time to join me and sharing your
experiences with the audience
to all of you out there
it's a real pleasure to be with you
thank you for the time you took
hopefully you
get a good glimpse of what drives our
roadmaps
and what we've delivered recently i hope
to come back and share much more with
you over time
and
also bring more conversations with
customers thank you
you